so our city is spoiling the homeless an
unsheltered woman in San Diego making a
shocking and blunted Mission about what
life is like on the streets there
to be homeless in San Diego is actually
not that hard because usually we're low
income and when you're low income you
get free phones
free food
free clothing I think it was boiled to
be honest with you
there's been an alarming surge in San
Diego's homeless population more than 2
000 people are living on the streets in
tents and encampments and it's gotten so
bad that the city council their banned
homeless encampments in public places
Dana gosh how generous of them San Diego
are very near and dear yeah Peter and I
lived in San Diego for three years
um we did love our time there and we
have good friends from there but I'm
really glad we left because the citizens
there the taxpayers I have a terrible
return on investment and I do Wonder but
you know in the Constitution I'm sorry
in the Declaration of Independence it
talks about the life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness well what happens
to the citizens the taxpaying citizens
about our Pursuit of Happiness had a
situation today I'm just all I was doing
was walking to work and this guy tries
to run me off the sidewalk yelling no no
no with his big cart and I just jumped
out of the way but I had to jump into
the street where all those crazy bikers
are and I thought after the Daniel Penny
situation when he's indicted for
manslaughter after this situation with
Jordan Neely on the subway like who's
who would who would help me I know New
Yorkers are awesome and if there'd
probably be somebody that would do that
but the incentive to help others protect
each one another from these people and
this authorities know who they are and
they're just throwing so much money at
the problem and I think that especially
remember the money that de Blasio gave
to his wife and supposed to help solve
the problem as soon as they left there
was an audit done and 850 million
dollars just went missing nobody knows
any idea where it went so a lot of these
homeless services that are getting a lot
of money more and more money it's not
working the solution is in listening to
the homeless like the woman who says we
are spoiled we need tough love or we're
never going to get off the street
Greg what do you think about that
approach I agree with everything the
little lady says and I'm sorry about the
cart
there's this assumption by on the part
of The Feelers like Jessica and Jesse's
mother
the unfeelers that is me and Jesse uh we
don't consider the empathy the
empathetic stance we have actually
that's the first rung of the latter
we're just on the fifth or sixth rung of
the ladder we've been through the
empathy part we're now in the different
stage and we want everybody else to join
us because it's been an uphill battle
dealing with this issue when you live in
the city and that's because the empathy
class has made the homeless a protected
class if you designate an offender
whether it is a criminal or or a drug
addict or a homeless person as a member
of the protective class if you complain
about it people will paint you as
heartless they will say bad things about
you and you don't want bad things said
about you so you never say anything
about it Jesse uh your mother made this
condemn your observation you said that
homelessness was a choice and she said
Don't Be Cruel well what is the big
picture you know what is what is causing
this homeless is is not based on the
lack of affordable housing that would be
like saying illegal immigration is based
on a lack of places to live that's not
the way it is it's where you prefer to
go the media Cherry picks stories of the
homeless that make it feel like it's you
know families and its veterans that may
be a tiny tiny part of this problem we
could solve that instantly it's mostly
young to middle-aged dudes who settle
into the life because it's not really
that bad Hobo's on heroin I mean think
about it you'll pay any bills you got no
mortgage you get free stuff I've been
thinking about it
but you know I like clean bathrooms
so as a feeling person and I think maybe
the only one on the table I did not like
what you just said Greg
Emily so there was Jesse's texts from
his mother okay uh there's a woman named
Mary Monroe who runs a homeless veterans
organization in San Diego who actually
went out to talk to the community and
she's put forward a plan to deal with
this which I thought seemed so smart and
basically to designate people by why
they are homeless to start with the
people that are the easiest to get off
the street which are people who've just
fallen on financial hard times then go
to people with mental health issues then
drug issues what about implementing
plants like that all over the country
yeah data analytics would be fantastic
unfortunately there's a dearth of it in
all of these compassionate approaches
because the real truth is that
compassion can be cruel that's what
we're seeing at the southern border
that's what we're seeing here so the
amount of investment the 200 billion
million dollars in San Diego one billion
dollars in Seattle over the last 10
years they just recently proposed a 12
billion dollar budget for context
Seattle Public Schools gets 1.14 billion
that's the priority because everyone has
these competing compassionate approaches
no no this is going to be the most the
most helpful the kindest the kid gloves
if you raise a child like that if you
raise them without boundaries without
any time of firmness without any type of
firmness of course that will just
exacerbate the problem we are
skyrocketing our taxpayer dollars into a
problem that is skyrocketing so clearly
that approach is not working I saw it in
Seattle all the time homeowners erecting
their own really expensive fences to
have some type of boundary next to the
encampment so they're paying taxes twice
why are we paying taxes that we are the
local
really it's the local and the state
governments have abdicated their Duty
100 to protect the citizens and to
protect your property values and any
chance of you pursuing your happiness
because they are prioritizing the
homeless
make your mom proud oh that's not
happening
you have to ask a liberal well we happen
to have one here is your goal to reduce
homelessness or is your goal to spend
money on homelessness because you're
spending money on homelessness and
you're not reducing it we can feel you
can feel you want to meddle for feeling
okay Greg's right we can feel bad and
then we can study the problem we can
understand the problem and we can take
action and you're not taking any action
you're subsidizing homelessness and
homelessness is increasing what do you
think happens when you let people sleep
on the street in tents that cost 300
from REI when you give them drugs when
you don't criminalize anything that they
do they're going to encourage more
homelessness well there's a story we did
last night on prime time in Portland
Portland spent 50 mil to build the
homeless Village
now it cost about 500 000 to build the
village they stole 49 million dollars so
they're stealing the money calling
themselves compassionate and increasing
homelessness it's a scam you know it I
know it even my mother knows it that's
amazing so this whole homeless activism
thing is a criminal Enterprise the
non-profits are raking it in yeah follow
the money just to keep on that Biden
family and anyone who cares about
homeless people I want to Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now